JANET CONRAD: You know, for
me, experimental physics
is a true joy.
I really love what I do.
I do neutrino physics.
I'm an experimentalist.
I think it is
absolutely fantastic.
And so, I believe that labs
should be really happy places.
And I want the
students to really find
what they're doing to be really
interesting, to really be
something that they care about.
And so, that's the
approach that I
like to take when
teaching junior lab.
I don't believe in this,
you break them down
to build them back up again.
I think that that
doesn't really work.
I really think that what you
do is you very gently lead
people and shape people.
You have them trust you, so that
the comments that you're making
are not taken wrong, that they
understand that that's to make
them a better physicist.
And I think that's
very important.
So that's sort of my approach.